KRISTAN UCCELLO: Hi.
My name's Krispy.
I'm a Developer Advocate on the
Cast Developer Relations team.
In this DevBytes
video, I will discuss
Google Cast receivers
and how development
works with Cast
receiver devices.
For this video, I'm
assuming you're already
familiar with the Cast
developer console.
If not, please
review the developer
console documentation.
Now, let's take a look at what
a receiver application is.
Cast receiver applications
are single-page HTML5 apps
that are loaded
from a network URL
and executed on a special
version of Chrome.
Cast receiver applications
run on Cast receiver devices
like a Chrome Cast.
Elements such as buttons,
links, and alerts
have been disabled since
there's no mouse or keyboard
input available.
All interactions with a running
Cast receiver application
happen through messages
sent by a Cast sender app.
To illustrate this
interaction model,
let's take a look at
how a Cast receiver
application is launched.
Cast receiver
applications are launched
when a Cast sender
application running
on a sender device such as
a phone, tablet, or computer
tells a receiver device that it
wants to launch an application.
What that application is
depends on the application ID
that the sender
provides when requesting
to use the receiver device.
The receiver device will look
up the application ID using
a Google service and load
the corresponding receiver
application associated with it.
Once the receiver
application is loaded,
it can start processing messages
from the connected sender
applications.
As a developer, you
have options when
it comes to the type of
receiver application launched
by a sender.
An application ID is a unique
ID for a receiver application
that you get when you
register a receiver
app in the Cast
developer console.
You can register an application
ID at cast.google.com/publish.
There are three types of
receiver applications,
two of which require
registration using
the Cast developer console,
and one that does not.
The one that doesn't is called
the Default Media Receiver,
and all it does is
play simple media.
No styling, no customization,
and no application ID.
There's no way to
modify its behavior.
The Styled Media
Receiver application
does require registration and
allows for some customization.
It's for playback
of simple media.
More on this in a moment.
Custom Receivers
are applications
that require registration and
are for building advanced media
players or other types of
TV applications like games.
A Styled Media Receiver
allows a sender application
to play media on a Cast
device without needing
to create your own Custom
Receiver application.
You can customize the
Styled Media Receiver color
scheme and branding by
providing your own CSS
during registration.
The Styled Media
Receiver is a great way
to get started building
Google Cast applications.
Using the Styled
Media Receiver means
developers can focus their
efforts on sender application
interactions without having
to build a custom receiver.
Creating a Styled
Media Receiver is
as easy as registering
for an application ID
through the Cast
developer console.
The Styled Media Receiver
is the best option
if the application does not
need to utilize advanced media
playback capabilities such
as adaptive streaming, DRM,
closed captioning,
or authentication.
Custom Receiver
applications are the way
to go if you want
to have control
over all aspects of the
behavior of your application.
With Custom Receivers, you can
support protocol name spaces
beyond just media and build
rich experiences for your users.
You have full control over the
presentation, interactions,
and more.
Using the Google
Cast receiver SDK,
you can build an HTML5
application, hook
into the various events that are
fired within the Cast Receiver
Message System, and
build complex behaviors
beyond simple media playback.
The Cast Receiver APIs
provide ways for developers
to build rich applications
targeting the TV space.
You can utilize the Cast
media player library
to build media applications
that use adaptive streaming.
HLS, MPEG DASH, smooth
streaming, and more.
They can also handle
authentication and use DRM.
In order to load a receiver
application onto a Cast device
while developing, register
the receiver devices
you wish to use in the
Cast developer console.
For an unpublished
receiver application,
only registered
Cast devices will
be able to load the
receiver application.
As well, during development,
the receiver device
will need to expose
its serial number.
This can be enabled using the
Chrome Cast setup application.
Simply select the Cast device
and enable the "Send serial
number when checking
for updates" option.
When you publish
your application,
any Cast receiver device
can load your app.
Now that I've covered some
of the basics of setting up
for development, let's
have a look at some code.
In a few lines of code, a
very basic Custom Receiver
application can be built
that plays simple media.
First, we load
the receiver APIs.
Then we ensure that we have
a video element, some media
element to play back
video, music, et cetera.
Once the window onload is fired,
identify the media element
and create a Cast media
manager to handle the sender
communication and media events.
Then get an instance of the
Cast receiver manager, which
is responsible for communicating
with the Cast system.
And tell it to start, which
lets the receiver device know
that the application is loaded
and ready to process sender
messages.
From here, you can build up
additional application logic.
And as you do, you
might want to know
how to debug your receiver code.
Thankfully, it's very simple
to debug receiver applications.
You can connect to
a device debugger
on a registered receiver by
opening Chrome on a computer
and going to the IP address
of the receiver device
on port 9222.
You can get the IP address
of the receiver device using
the Chrome Cast setup app.
The debugger has full DOM
manipulation and JavaScript
console support.
To keep logs between
sessions, click the gear icon
in the lower right and check
the box next to "Preserve
log upon navigation."
We are very excited to see what
you build with Google Cast.
To get you going,
we're providing
a number of resources.
You can discover more details
about the Google Cast SDK
at developers.google.com/cast.
The design checklist will
go a long way in guiding you
down the path to creating great
second screen applications.
You can find sample senders
and sample receiver apps
at gethub.com/googlecast.
Post your questions
on Stack Overflow
and tag them with Google-cast.
In future DevBytes,
we will dive deeper
into the Cast sender SDK for
each platform and Cast receiver
SDK.
Join the Google Cast developer
community on Google+ for pro
tips and share your experiences.
It's now up to you to go out
and create great Google Cast
receiver applications.
Happy casting.